[Applause]
and
they're back the unmistakable sight and
sound
of english fans aboard
[Applause]
portuguese police intervened on a couple
of occasions last night
to diffuse what was largely good-natured
rivalry
between manchester city and chelsea
supporters
throughout the day they commandeered one
of the prettiest corners of this city
twelve thousand ticket holders and many
more are in porto
this is the biggest mass departure from
the uk since before the pandemic
and under a watchful presence wetting
their appetite for the biggest club
match in world football
does it feel like a little bit of
normality in europe again yes
definitely normality's definitely coming
back
and i would say to everyone [ __ ] holiday
and get over here but it's fun
how much have you paid to get out here
in total we're ticking everything like
brandon
this final was originally slated for
istanbul but was moved to portugal
because the country's on the uk
government's travel
greenless the beautiful setting of porto
is just a bonus but with the indian
covered variant on the rise in england
and so many fans traveling here
there's no doubt that this city has
taken a risk
but the mayor says it's worth it the
fact is people need to work
and this gives a city a new a new life i
see so many people in the street this
morning i was walking in the street
plenty of people around and uh the cafes
are full
people are enjoying uh and and we are
showing the city which is so important
and then of course
remember porto is a city where people
like the game they love the game
for manchester city it's the first
european final in 51 years
for this man a chance to crown a
reputation already cemented as the most
influential manager of a generation i'm
pretty sure you have to suffer to win
the finals it's not
uh you know go out there and enjoy so
it's worth it's night but sometimes it's
not possible so
sometimes you have most of the times in
the finals you have to suffer you have
to be resilient
chelsea are the slight underdogs despite
having beaten
city twice this season their manager
thomas tuchel giving his squad some
light relief with an impression of his
opposite number guardiola
until he spotted the camera watching i
will never
suggest that it's me against him because
we don't we don't we don't have a match
of tennis we arrive with our teams and
pep will prepare his team and i will
prepare my team in the best way possible
i
we have two experiences now against them
in different competitions
and two different matches to different
lineups
last year the champions league trophy
was lifted before
empty stands today many of these
supporters will be inside
the stadio do dragao but the joy of
having them back is tempered by a fear
among police
that the negative aspects of england
travelling fans
may return to martha calmer sky news
porto